did your parents send you pet care
packages when you went to university
if i say no they might say otherwise
they might like that you don't remember
you might see this episode like we send
you things
i don't think they did i i want to say
that no i don't think so
i remember the last house i moved into
in university
it was like
we moved in it was a bit beat up it
wasn't like great
my mum was like mortified she was like
oh my god this place is a [ __ ]
oh my god you can't be caught literally
i'm like it's not that bad i'll get over
it i'll be fine i just remember her
reaction she was just like i thought she
was actually gonna be like you can't you
can't you have to find somewhere else
this is too awful i was like
it wasn't even that bad it was kind of
messy is this the one in swansea yeah
but it was and that one was the one that
later had like rats
i don't think the rats were a part of
the initial moving in thing they joined
later they moved in with me they were
the other roommates yeah the package no
i didn't i didn't i didn't pre-order
those unfortunately
uh yeah no i mean [ __ ] i i think that
everything i i only ever had like white
roommates actually sounds very i guess
in swansea there isn't much diversity
there was
i did have some friends who are from
like uh from from chinese schools mm-hmm
but most of them didn't expect students
or they just a lot of a lot of foreign
students come to right right yeah
there's a
there's a very like the uk is a lot of
foreign students yeah i like sansa um
there's a ton of universities i think
there's one every city has two yeah you
guys have like some of the highest
universities yeah yeah yeah and it's
quite a lot of prestigious ones yeah not
swansea but you know maybe another
prestigious one yeah yeah
yeah maybe oxford was full yeah
yeah so i i had some friends that were
chinese but they didn't speak much
english right right and
there was such a i can't remember his
name
he
i had did some projects with him in
first year and he was like didn't know
what the [ __ ] was going on right so we
kind of just helped we were like we'll
just we'll just help you we'll just do
it and he was like thank you thank you
i'll return the favor
and then you never know
never saw him again right
and then two years later same
engineering i was like oh my god i saw
him again i was like man and his english
was a bit better yeah
a bit more english still wasn't like
great but it was pretty good
and uh he was really struggling with
this thing and we we had a spare slot in
our group and we were like just just
join ours because we're basically nearly
done yeah yeah you get a passing grade
like and he was like oh [ __ ] no way and
i'll be like what do you do for fun he's
like i'll show you
no no dead ass we're like in the like
computer libraries just working on this
thing this is when we like invited him
to join us yeah right and we were like
we were just talking so we were he was
sitting with us and we're like oh yeah
what do you do he's like i'll show you
so he takes us outside he starts
breakdancing
just like insane like insane yeah insane
because he didn't want to explain it or
something yeah i don't know what it was
he just starts doing like insane like
flips and [ __ ] yeah we were like we're
like computer nerds and like engineers
and we're just like
what
what is this
that's [ __ ] awesome he was so bizarre
and then the glow up dude yeah
and he was like he's like yeah i love
breakdancing it's my passion and stuff
yeah and i was like i was like nice dude
i'm nice she's like what are you going
to do after this he's like i [ __ ]
know
he's like he's like i'm just i'm just
i'm just here until my parents dragged
me back and i was like i have a paranoid
breakdance my way to work and so he was
like he was like by the way i didn't
forget i wanna i wanna i wanna i wanna
return the favor for you help you guys
help me so much oh yeah yeah and uh i
didn't see him for a long time and then
one day i was on the bus
back to like the
my house and he was there he was like
dude let me return the favor for you
yeah and i was like oh okay sure sure
and so we go into town he's like look my
friend owns this boba store and i'm like
i'm like of course
[Music]
i'm like yeah i don't want to be racist
it makes sense
chinese friends on the boba street yeah
yeah that makes sense
my first time ever having bobo he's like
yeah you've got to try this this is
amazing oh really you love tea i'm like
yeah i love tea i love yeah i've never
heard of boba before right this is like
20
is this before it like exploded yeah
this is like the explosion yeah and i've
never even seen this stuff and they were
putting these these what i thought were
balls into my drink tapioca yeah
he puts them in i'm like i don't know
man it looks kind of this isn't like tea
i've had before
and it's and it's cold yeah yeah i don't
know about that so i have this and he
makes it for me and it's he's like it's
pretty charged free of charge i'm like
okay okay okay
i'm like all right i'll give you like
i don't know how much this work would
have cost if i charged you but all right
all right
three bar i'm very grateful and i drink
it and immediately like
i'm like choking on this [ __ ] tapioca
ball i'm like oh
i'm like you got a heimlich
it's awful i like spat out the boba i
mean this straw is so bad
i suck on it like the widest thing ever
that is the wildest story i've ever
heard white man tries tapioca literally
literally spat it out and i was like i'm
sorry i'm so sorry he's like no this is
it was funny and i'm like
i'm like but the milk part the milk pop
tasted good yeah can we get rid of the
balls and he's like yeah we'll just make
you another one without the ball no no
you don't have to use like it's free
don't worry like ah
okay i got you bro i was like okay okay
okay that's nice of him yeah he's very
very nice god i remember when the
[ __ ] initial boba explosion happened
in japan how did that happen why did
that happen that's so weird because like
yeah the
the month we moved here it was like
every boba store you could you would
tell which boba store what was a boba
store sorry yeah if it had a line
outside yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah right there there were some bubble
stores near my house at the time where
it was like legit like on weekends it
was legit like a four-hour wait yeah and
i'm like i don't get it what i don't get
it it's uh it's just a bit of tea with
some jelly
oh yeah it like [ __ ] sped run death
dude like i like
speed run death i think it's still one
yeah no listen you never see you go to a
boba store now there's like maybe one or
two people there
that's true well this there's still a
thing in the uk from what i can see
there's still like exists the stores i
don't know it's like it's still around
but it's not just it's just the hype i
mean rightly so because i thought it was
like overrated the [ __ ] i think so i did
i didn't get what the craze around it
was i mean i drank i drank a shitload of
it during uni because we had like a
bubble store near like where we studied
but like i get it yeah but that was
before the explosion it lasts a while
because it's cold so you can kind of
just sip on it throughout the day if you
ever get a big one also if you're a uni
student it's a great sugar rush yeah
it's also like keeps you concentrated i
guess everyone everyone after a while
was like in japan at least we're like
all right back back to starbucks now
yeah back to start back to the way life
should have been i just i just i just i
saw nothing with just iced tea or iced
coffee i don't know maybe it too to me
it was like
honestly but it's not fun there's no
there's no personality i'm a hot boy i
like i like my drinks hot i don't really
like cold drinks
they're hot boba too though right i
think hop over is just not the same
yeah i think they do but it's not it's
not as good i believe you can order it
with like no ice sometimes you know when
you can customize your lukewarm though
that's lukewarm it's like piss water
yeah i don't know i don't know what
maniac would order warm boba but it was
an option in some of the beaufort stores
i've been to it was like a specialty i'd
i'd be like okay if you said something
is that was that a secret menu did you
have a secret menu
[Music]
but i remember just like not just in
japan but just pretty much
everywhere in the uk everywhere in
thailand you just couldn't get away from
it even in the states
it was like fashionable i think it's a
fashionable drink yeah i guess so and i
think it's instagramable that's yeah
that's
instagram
let's be honest 2014 was just uh it was
all like the frappuccino that's what it
was that's right
that was the thing everyone just wants a
photogenic drink and boba looked
photogenic but i feel japan took that
like the photogenic-ness of boba and
just like was trying to stretch it out
to
such a high degree where it was just so
unnecessary it's like everything in
japan though everything's about taking
photos like afternoon tea i love my
afternoon tea it's the most british
thing i've ever said i really really
enjoy going for tea and having crumpets
or scones that is like a weirdly popular
subculture in japan isn't it it is but
everywhere i've been just does it really
badly really they they
okay i mean not badly oh it's hard to
say not as good like i to me afternoon
tea is just as much about like the food
you get as it is the tea yeah right
right and the food isn't great here it's
it's the food here looks so aesthetic
but it doesn't taste good yeah that's
literally all they do is they make they
arrange it and they get these like
beautiful colored things then you take
one bite of the quiche you're like why
does it taste bad yes i
actually agree so that this is like
afternoon tea is one thing that england
does
the best that i've had so far because
the the afternoon tea food is actually
good whereas in japan every time i've
had afternoon tea it just looks pretty
also yeah it's got to be layered right
yeah so like the layers are to
distinguish the types of flavors right
bottom is for sandwiches then maybe you
get like the the quiches or the more
like savory kind of uh like kind of the
dishes it's always sandwiches pastries
yeah yeah and so so it's like savory
sweet savory and then sweets yeah but in
japan it's sweet
sweet
savory and also sweet but it's like it's
ridiculous it's like this isn't because
normally afternoon tea you kind of have
it at like we have in the afternoon yeah
but you know if if it's a good place you
can only like skip lunch or dinner with
it because it's pretty like it's quite a
lot yeah some places even refill yeah in
the uk they refill the sandwiches or
stuff in some places so you can just
like you can chow down dude yeah if you
like the sandwiches or you like the
whatever they're offering dude it's good
it's so good money's worth yeah
expensive though
in london it's very expensive yeah i bet
yeah it's good it's really good
but it's an experience you're paying for
right yeah yeah yeah
one thing i've only seen really in asia
as well going off like the boba thing
before like i guess the baby questions
the coolest thing i've ever mentioned by
the way i just realized that someone
said privilege maybe like the tea isn't
good enough
it's disgusting no sandwiches i mean i
mean it's one thing i feel like britain
does well so i i think it's a good it's
no great so is it just right
yeah like uh
dessert dessert cafes that's that's one
thing like i only saw in asia oh yeah
and i don't i don't know if there is
more dessert cafes in this
it's it's like
it's literally exactly that think of a
buffet but it's all desserts yeah
because whenever i'd hang out with my uh
like some of my friends in thailand
they'd be like oh let's go to this
dessert cafe i'm just like wait like to
me growing up in england dessert was
something you have at the end of a meal
at a restaurant right you don't go to a
specific place to eat dessert right that
was that concept was just alien to me
yeah and like i to me i it still feels
weird right because
i would like if i want dessert after a
meal i would order it at the restaurant
yeah but like you go to a dessert cafe
and it's like it's like half a meal you
know
you know you know because like you never
you never go to a dessert cafe after you
finish eating at a restaurant yeah but
you go to a dessert cafe at like really
weird times the other day and yeah yeah
three or something yeah i go to a
dessert cafe i have to dessert and then
it just [ __ ] with my eating schedule
because then i just don't want dinner
yeah then it also doesn't fill me up as
well it's it's really weird so you get
hungry at like 9 00 p.m yeah it's like a
really weird time where it's like oh
it's kind of too late to eat food yeah
right
but i'm i know i won't be able to sleep
because i'm going to get hungry yeah
yeah no i get that yeah i don't i don't
want it i don't know i just don't feel
satisfied if i've eaten a lot of
something sweet but yeah when i eat like
a savory meal yeah i just feel like
happy i just feel sick if i eat too much
sweet stuff now yeah yeah i was always
like that though like i could never eat
two i like sweets but like i could never
eat too much of it because then i just
get i'd be filled up but then the that
feeling of being filled up by sweet [ __ ]
just made me feel really ill
which just made me want to eat regular
food anyway